hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Adele and
we're gonna talk about a movie today
that a lot of fans have been asking us
to watch it's called old boy the Korean
version the 2003 film I don't know why
everyone asked me to watch this film
it's uh sure
that could be the word for hit
disturbing disturbing on many levels
yeah I've seen a lot of like torture
porn kind of movies for some reason this
is just so psychologically [ __ ] up I
was like oh my god I kinda have to watch
it like through my eyes sometimes not
because I mean what's happening is very
violent and graphic at times but it's
also the psychological effect that it's
having on me I just wanted to not come
out of the screen and get me yeah
exactly
like there's that one scene where he's
there's gonna be some spoilers and that
one scene where he cuts off his tongue
with the scissors you don't see it
happen but it's incredibly disturbing
when it's happening like just the angle
of it and the shaking of the hand and
the sound of the sound
yeah cutting through the tongue oh my
goodness and incest through the roof in
this film man when I was first watching
that first incest scene house like this
is this is disgust I was so bothered and
then when you find out it's the guy's
daughter it like holy [ __ ] they talked
to the first incest plot that was nuts
just when you think you're safe and it's
not gonna get any worse it gets worse
easy I never saw any footage or a
trailer of this one but I saw the
trailer for the remake which no one
liked but I saw the trailer for it and
it was like okay there's gonna be some
cool revengefully and so I thought I was
going in for like a cool Korean revenge
flick yeah and it's not that it is like
it's a revengeful buddy film is that on
a whole different its execution is just
beyond different like it's just taking
vengeance to a whole new life stead
occation of how much time and planning
and
years that you'll put into connecting
your revenge on somebody who you feel is
wrong do you or your family yeah like
what I do appreciate about it is like
it's not weird but the incest part
doesn't make sense
I appreciate the incest invisible
because like for someone have you locked
up for 15 years like that like torture
someone like that for 15 years and then
like you know put him on a [ __ ] route
it's like it is like kind of clever
actually like in terms of writing
because you do need like an extreme
reason to do this at someone so yeah no
it was in and yeah the villain was good
it was kind of he was just psychotic in
fact he kind of made me feel a little
bit like Heath Ledger's Joker from sack
night yeah because he just is doing it
this these chaotic things for these
reasons that are almost unexplainable
and that don't make sense to normal
people yeah and it's like he's like a
classic villain in the sense that he's
just so consistent in being a bad guy
like no matter what happened it's
actually what he's living for the only
reason keeping him alive is this guy but
the main guy day-to-day - oh dae-su yeah
that that guy um fantastic actor by the
way in the beginning you see him as a
drunk and he's totally believable this
is drunk and then through the course of
the 15 years and who he comes out being
he's totally believable it is that
[ __ ] like psychotic breakdown going
back to the bad guy where he's just when
he is just breaking down about making
sure the guy does not tell his daughter
of the fact that he's been you know
she's been [ __ ] is her father's very
I think that there's like it's kind of
like a Greek tragedy it's like fate you
know he tries once he's released from
the jail laughs at 15 years he's trying
to do the right thing and and but
everything he does is the wrong thing
which is revealed at the end like yeah
yeah it's just like an escalation of not
escalation it's a downfall it's like the
worst kind of downfall to experience
it's the car crash the
can't look away from oh god yeah like
that scene when he was having that
breakdown was like that's a brave
[ __ ] actor like he really commits a
lot to every moment in this film this
film is not an action piece at all it's
a violent movie it's violent there's a
lot of violence I mean the one kind of
action scene like your favorite scenes
on the Holloway corridor scene that's
the only part that's like in action
scene in a way hold on in one shot all
done in one shot
and it seems believable to like if that
fight really went down and like I could
see it going down that way yeah that's
cool I liked I was like an imaginary
training actually get me to where I am
and that was pretty [ __ ] sweet you
know when he was doing he's like
training and then you know you see him
become a fighter and like this makes
sense this is for what the world they
created and the characters they created
they really stayed 100% invested in all
of it so even if you don't like this
film it kind of got a respected for what
it did it's really balls out and and how
it makes you feel I mean there's
something about a movie that can make
you feel so disturbed on so many levels
you just you can't if you watch it
you're gonna be affected by it
yeah it was good not you have no soul
exactly exactly
you incest lovers out there but about
the ending ending not just the ending
they're like PostScript in the snow
ending oh yeah where it kind of leaves
you and like limbo yeah he tries to
forget what he's done
tries to be hypnotized to put it all
behind him just that little open ending
door at the end you know did he really
forget it all is it something that he'll
never be able to forget yeah because he
starts off laughing and then he's crying
all of a sudden and it's like are you
remembering everything it's pretty
[ __ ] disturbing that that's the key
word of this review right disturbing
disturbing mm-hmm and one thing this
movie does a lot is they really honor
the themes going on like there's a lot
of repeated quotes in this film yes they
do go with those those proverbs and
sayings quite a lot in fact I think at
some points that
ohdo soothes even like saying some feels
like poetry
it's kind of voice overing some of his
stuff that's happening so it's kind of
like a [ __ ] up korean version of film
noir but i would call this well adel
really likes a quote that i want to talk
about is that goes watch i'm remembering
this off the top of my head it's not
written down on my laptop in front of me
be it a rock or a grain of sand wow I'm
so good in water they sink as the same
Patel tell me your thoughts on this I
actually want to hear your thoughts what
well I I don't know I kind of felt like
it had something to do with the crime
that aren't I sooo committed and it
doesn't matter if it's an atrocious
quick atrocity type of crime like
against humanity or it's a small crime
like he spread this rumor which
escalated to something different it's a
crime and that's why the villain in the
movie is punishing him even though I'm
no more than a monster don't die to have
the right to live like that is like a
big theme in this [ __ ] movie for sure
daddy'd oh my god I just finished
watching this film a few minutes ago I
have like this pain like in my heart
right here I felt like my heart was
moving around a little bit sometimes I
thought it was like I'm gonna come out
my mouth you know thanks for telling me
about it I mean I don't regret watching
it's a weird film to say I like a lot at
times I kind of love it at the end of
day I just really respect their
commitment to what they were doing I
think that even if you don't love a film
like this you have to absolutely respect
how it makes you feel and the kind of
fucked-up things that it makes you think
about and contemplate mm-hmm because
even if you don't like the feelings
you're feeling that's the directors
intent though you wanted you to feel
that way
so it's like hey the director's vision
you got his job done yeah made you feel
really upsetting and then there are two
more movies in this sort of three
trilogy type of theme sympathy for Lady
vengeance and they all kind of follow
those themes of vengeance revenge
justice personal justice and vigilantism
I want to see those films yeah but I'll
give myself a couple of years
you should see them all imagine looking
all free yeah I know right
would be really messed up I do not
recommend watching the three of them
back-to-back well thank you guys for
telling us about this if you're new to
the channel you can subscribe right here
and Adele has her own you can't call it
a movie review channel sure Adele has
her own movie review channel called roll
credits there's a link to her channel in
the description box and right here well
thank you guys for watching thank you
I'm gonna go throw up now